hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my first Jessica Jones episode video
just because of the way everything's
dropping these videos are gonna work a
little bit different but this is gonna
be all about episodes one through four
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
started watching jessica jones yet and
there really is no right way to watch it
because it's netflix they drop it all at
once you can totally do that raise your
hand if you actually stayed up all night
to finish every single episode nobody
that I've seen on Twitter or Facebook
has made it past like episode 10 yet so
most people will watch like a block of
episodes take a break then come back
later but I'll start off with a really
interesting fact about the series itself
just just like the actual production of
it the showrunner Melissa Rosenberg said
that originally they were selling the
project to ABC and I think we're all
really glad that that didn't end up
happening because if they had done this
series for ABC it would not be nearly as
cool as it is now they would had to tone
all the cool stuff down it would have
been way less dark way less gritty way
more formulaic but when it was still at
ABC the Patsy Walker character was
intended to be Carol Danvers
that's right Captain Marvel but what
happened is is this was a long time ago
way before Avengers age of Ultron went
down and if you remember she was
originally supposed to be an Avengers
age of Ultron - Captain Marvel but plans
changed the Jessica Jones TV show went
to Netflix Marvel Studios ended up
changing their movie plans and Captain
Marvel got her own movie so they had to
take her out of the Netflix series and
put in the Patsy Walker Hellcat
character and if you're not familiar
Patsy Walker is Hellcat from the comics
she does have special powers that I'll
talk about as I as they're talking about
all the characters but as much as there
are a bunch of references to the comic
books in this Jessica Jones TV series
it's not as connected to the MCU as it
used to be when it was ABC the party
line was just like agents of shield
everything is connected the Netflix
shows are still technically connected
because they reference a lot of things
that happen in the movies but they don't
weave in with the plot quite as much
like don't expect a whole bunch of Civil
War set up in this I'll say my initial
reaction to the series is that it is a
better character based TV show then
anything else Marvel has done or really
anything else that's on TV right now
daredevil is an amazing TV show it's
also better than most TV shows in
existence but it's more of a traditional
crime drama Jessica Jones is more of a
character study but you're just drilling
deep into everyone's psyche why everyone
is
doing what they're doing daredevil does
take the time to get into the characters
heads but not nearly as much as Jessica
Jones so I feel like people that will
walk away liking daredevil more than
Jessica Jones are just a fan of more
traditional plot based TV shows than
they are like intense character study
like one of the big scenes that
everyone's talking about is when Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage have super-powered
sex like there's there's a couple
different times they have sex the first
time they have sex is super awkward
because they don't know each other as
powers just cos like it's okay I'm not
fragile I'm not gonna break because she
is super tough Luke Cage not knowing
that she has super powers it's like no
you will definitely break I need to slow
down but the fact that they're having
sex isn't that special characters on a
lot of TV shows have sex it's the way
Jessica Jones portrays it's sex scenes
it's super intense and super personal
and because the Jessica character hasn't
really come out of her shell as of the
first couple of episodes she just she's
like she can't handle the intensity so
that's why when she's staring at Luke
Cage she gets that weird look on her
face and she has to turn around she
can't look him in the eye when they're
having sex like it's just too personal
for her until we get to Episode three
when she starts to come out of her shell
a little bit they finally come clean
about their powers their backstories and
it becomes a much more traditional
comfortable sex scene despite the comedy
of them breaking everything with their
super sex
speaking of comedy I think my favorite
funniest moment in the first four
episodes at least or when Jessica
finally gets so pissed with her upstairs
neighbors making noise that she bangs on
the door and finds out that they're
twins and it turns into this weird game
of Thrones twincest joke I don't give a
bag of dicks what kind of kinky [ __ ]
you're into as long as you do it quietly
favorite line so far in the series her
upstairs neighbors are actually a good
barometer for what's going on inside her
head she starts out she can't handle
people she's in super loner mode she's
like I can't be around people I'm a
danger to people and people are a danger
to me like I don't know what's gonna be
around the next corner so she just
isolates herself but finally because of
this hope case and kilgrave coming back
she gets sick of everything she's like
fine I'm gonna do something about it so
that's kind of reflected in the way she
treats her upstairs neighbors and then
eventually she gets a little more
comfortable with their weirdness even
though she still calls them out on it
like when the dude tells her that they
have tinfoil on all their windows and
she's like wait a minute I don't I don't
want to know I don't want to know why
but the interesting thing about the
Jessica Jones character yes
it's like an intense character study for
her but the same issues that Jessica
Jones is dealing with all the other
characters are dealing with them too
especially her friend Patsy Walker who
you find out what some hilarity is
turning herself into a ninja slowly like
she feels completely powerless like I
can't help I don't have special powers
so she's also kind of locking herself
away in her special fortress from the
world the same way Jessica Jones does
but let's talk about some of the big
Easter eggs the earliest one is actually
the opening scene where she talks about
catching people boning in alleys she
gives the evidence to her client he gets
all pissed and she smashes him through
the window that's an actual line in a
panel right out of her alias comic but
really the biggest Easter eggs are the
characters that they pull from the
comics jeryn hogarth here who might end
up turning into something of a villain
at a certain point crazy intense shark
lawyer who seems like Jessica's friend
or at least gives her jobs this is a
gender bent version of jeryn hogarth
from the comics in the comics it's a
male character he works for Rand Meacham
he's also a lawyer but Rand Meacham is
Danny rands family's company it's like
their version of Wayne Enterprises so
that's the connection to iron fist the
jeryn hogarth character there is a lot
of rumors going around about the iron
fist Netflix series maybe it's happening
maybe they're doing something different
with it Joe Quesada actually just said
that they are working on an iron fist
Netflix series so I would take him at
his word but the interesting thing about
jeryn hogarth
is as they turned it into a much bigger
character that she has her own subplot
that's going on with her wife here and
the person she's married to is calamity
jane from Deadwood which i think is just
awesome but there's this whole thing
with her cheating getting divorced from
her and then she finds out about
killgrave and she's like wow the things
that we could do if we could make him
work for us and of course when jessica
hears her wandering about that she's
just like WTF this person is a
psychopath so I'm kind of wondering if
the jeryn hogarth character is gonna try
and save kilgrave from jessica jones so
that she can use him for her legal
practice because she was talking about
this big 50 million dollar case so just
put a tab in that like jeryn hogarth
might wind up being one of the villains
of the series even though she starts out
seeming like a friend Jessica really
needs to find some new attorneys if only
there were some avocado Bros that could
help her out for the second big
character obviously the patsy walker
Hellcat character the really interesting
thing about the way they tease
characters out
is how they explain their backstories
like Jessica throws Patsy's mother in
her face and she's like low blow Jess
but you don't find out about her mother
too many episodes later
so they'll tease back story with a turn
of phrase and then actually explained it
in a later episode so I just I love the
way their seating story's out it's
really like one story told over thirteen
hours instead of a traditional TV show
where you have a different story every
single week one of my favorite moments
is when patsy walker accidentally takes
down that fan and then he says i really
missed the red hair that's just a
reference to her comic book character in
the comics patsy walker when she does
have her Hellcat powers has red hair
let's talk about Luke Cage he's
obviously going to be getting his own TV
series and Mike Mike Colter actually did
say that somatically stylistically the
Luke Cage TV show will look way
different from Jessica Jones but when
Luke Cage is telling Jessica Jones about
his origins he says experiment he was
framed for drug possession thrown in
prison while in prison he was allowed to
participate in the said experiment and
it was a modified version of the Captain
America super soldier program so he was
bombarded with this organic electrical
field and that's how he got his
super-strength and his super tough skin
it's a little more complicated than that
he was actually undergoing the
super-soldier treatment and another
character came in and sabotage the
controls and that led to the accident
that gave him his powers so we're about
in the timeline that has already
happened in Luke Cage is just trying to
hide out like he's like I don't need the
police up in my business
you see all this paranoia about people
that are gifted they use the term gifted
but really they're talking about anybody
with powers that also includes Inhumans
so like when Jessica is serving papers
to that douchebag character and she's
like I have laser eyes obviously very
timely Superman referenced but you just
you get the sense that this exists
inside the Marvel Cinematic Universe
they also reference the alien attack but
I haven't heard any reference to
Terrigen mist or fish oil pills yet now
the girl that Luke Cage has a picture of
in his bathroom is his ex-wife
that's Reva Connors from the comics the
reason jessica is so sad is because it's
the same girl the kilgrave had her kill
we don't know exactly why but Reva
Connors was luke cage's girlfriend in
the comics before he became Power Man
now in the TV show obviously she runs
afoul of kilgrave but in the comic books
she runs
foul of Diamondback which is a character
that's gonna be in the Luke Cage TV
series but if there was any confusion
like this woman is not misty Knight
misty Knight is actually gonna be a new
character in the Luke Cage TV series so
we'll see her but you can see why they
made this change they just they want to
give Jessica some history with Luke Cage
that did not previously exist in the
comic books but if you were confused
about why Jessica Jones was initially
investigating Luke Cage she lies and
says that she was on a case trying to
catch him boning with a married woman
but then the woman comes back later and
is like I don't know why you were
investigating him and taking pictures
are you a stalker because my husband did
not hire you she was investigating Luke
Cage because she knows that he is
connected to the woman that she is
haunted by the woman that she killed
moving on to David Tennant kilgrave one
of the best Marvel villains so far and
we've only seen a little bit of him he
gets the exact same type of introduction
that kingpin does during the daredevil
series like you see the back of their
head first you hear them speak but you
don't see their face till later making
the little girl go to the bathroom in
the closet so terrible but you're just
like oh man this is gonna be so amazing
and so awful for the first couple of
episodes is all about Jessica realizing
that he's still alive
she thinks that she left him for dead in
the same accident where she killed luke
cage's ex-wife but she slowly tracks him
down with a big Grey's Anatomy Easter
Egg which I thought was hilarious what
hospital are you from Seattle Grace oh
you mean like the one on TV so he
learned some really interesting stuff
about him he is you know just as
psychologically damaged as Jessica or
any of the other characters he's
completely obsessed with Jessica despite
the fact like jeryn hogarth is like Oh
think of the power that this man has but
he uses his powers for such mundane
things like he just wants to get dinner
he just wants to get Jessica back what's
he gonna do with her really small
trivial stuff kilgrave if he wanted
could be way more powerful but because
he has so many psychological problems
he's always gonna be tied up doing
[ __ ] small stuff so we learned about
his flaws but I think one of the most
interesting lines about him in the first
couple of episodes the doctor has that
line where he's like I told him you
could survive just fine with one kidney
but no he wanted to be made whole and
how completely messed up was it when she
went to visit the person on the dialysis
machine
the person who helped kill Grape Escape
his accident and he writes kill me on
that pad of paper and she's just like I
can't I can't
he just wind up staring you're TV going
oh my god but here's my big questions
for you guys let me know in the comments
what is your favorite funny moment so
far and what is your favorite most
messed up moment so far so what I'm
gonna do for my next Jessica Jones video
is I'll do episodes five through eight
so I'll just do like blocks of four
episodes I'll try to do a video every
day but I might end up having to skip
Sunday there's also a new flash arrow
crossover extended trailer with a bunch
of new footage of Hawkgirl Hawkman so
I'll do a video for that later tonight
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and I will be live tweeting
some of the episodes I'll try to be as
non-spoilery as possible
but if you don't know where my twitter
and facebook are there are links in the
description while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for my Jessica Jones playlist it's where
I'm adding all my new Jessica Jones
videos and you can click here for the
flash arrow crossover trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you